[Music]
welcome to the 2013 keynote session
especially as this is our 40th
anniversary um i was very excited to
celebrate with a very unique and special
keynote session to celebrate the
pioneers of the animation arts
the opportunity arose early in the
planning process to do a collaboration
with the academy of motion arts and
sciences was absolutely thrilled to have
this relationship
we'd like to especially thank disney
legend alice davis who's here with us
today she gave her approval to allow us
to use our keynote as part of the mark
davis lecture series it's named after
her late husband mark davis
this lecture series is managed by the
academy and it provides a forum for all
film experts to explore challenges and
creating as well as
producing and executing feature films
to kick off the session here i'd like to
introduce randy haberkamp randy is from
the academy and he's going to come to
the stage and introduce all of our
panelists
good morning
the academy is really honored to have
the mark davis lecture uh here at
seagraph's as key c graphs keynote today
the academy of course has had arts and
sciences in its name for 85 years so the
idea of left brain right
is part of our dna as well first i want
to thank academy member ron diamond of
acme filmworks for not only helping us
to produce this event but also for
advising the academy film archive on
making sure that the student work of the
animation community is preserved by our
academy film archive to serve as
inspiration and insight for future
filmmakers
we're going to show you some brief
snippets
from our panelists student work
you'll also be able to see the entire
films today uh at the daytime selects at
4 30 in room 207 so i suspect that
you'll get into each clip just as it
shuts off i suspect we may hear some
just like we heard at the rehearsal so
that's your chance to see the complete
films
since 1994 the academy has been
presenting the mark davis animation
celebration and mark davis was our first
presenter he's known of course uh for
many of his characters not the least of
which are tinkerbell and um corella
deville but also for his work as an
imagineer at disneyland
the first lecture was given the year of
the lion king which reflecting back now
is regarded as a real resurgence of the
popularity and artistic success of
theatrical animated motion pictures and
before toy story would signal a dramatic
mark davis is often remembered as one of
walt disney's nine old men
the nine animators he was referring to
at that time were in their 40s and it
was a joking reference to president
franklin roosevelt's calling the supreme
court nine old men all too aged to
remember and recognize a new idea
the disney nine of course went on to
produce many years of classic animation
before they grew into the actual nine
old men that they referred to
with age for animation historians
disney's nine old men are now remembered
as pillars of feature animation and many
of them including mark davis mentored
many of the panelists on our stage today
which is the focus of our presentation
ironically and symbolically we ended up
with nine animated feature directors
with us today though they really don't
qualify yet as nine old men
but having them with us for the first
mark davis animation lecture to be held
outside the academy's beverly hills
headquarters seemed appropriate as we
celebrate mark's centennial year
with his lovely wife alice here to
witness it all who was
alice wanted to be an animator but at
the time
women couldn't be animators even though
we have nine men on stage today we tried
diligently to get some women to join us
they were all busy and we hope to have
them here at another time so
advances have been made on many fronts
and we continue to work in that regard i
want to thank seagraph for having us
here and in the meantime i hope you'll
check us check this out and tell your
friends about this
keynote which will be available on
youtube and at oscars.org
our first guest is
kirk wise
kirk come on out please
kirk earned his paycheck for first
paycheck for drawing at age seven after
his mother submitted his sketch to the
san francisco chronicles junior art
champion contest
following graduation from cal arts he
contributed animation and storyboarding
to various projects including the disney
animated features the great mouse
detective and brave little toaster he
worked with fellow animator gary
truesdale to read story credits on the
features oliver and company and the lion
king and the two would go on to direct
beauty and the beast and hunchback of
notre dame and atlantis the lost empire
more recently he served as story
consultant on the sony pictures animated
feature open season oversaw the early
development of cloudy with a chance of
meatballs and served as an executive
producer on the disney nature
documentary oceans but here is a scene
from kirk's
student film child proof
our next guest is david silverman david
david received his mfa from ucla in 1983
he worked in feature free and freelance
illustration and animation until landing
a job on the tracy ullman show where the
simpsons got their start as short
segments he animated all 48 shorts and
directed many of the episodes
becoming supervising animation director
as well as producer of the simpsons in
1992 he then went on to dreamworks to
co-direct the road to el dorado to pixar
to co-direct monsters inc and to blue
sky to do writing and storyboarding for
ice age and robots he returned to the
series simpsons at the end of 2003 as
supervising director and directed the
simpsons movie in 2007 and received an
oscar nomination for the animated short
maggie simpson in the longest daycare
this year
but here's a glimpse of david's student
film the strange case of mr donnie
brooks boredom
pretty soon he began to count sheep
[Music]
mrs donny brook began to count sheep too
after a while
mr dybrook said hey
you're counting my sheep
stop counting my sheep
well the very idea
i suppose i know my own sheep don't they
no long now
they're cattle
that's how
our next guest is henry selick
henry studied painting drawing
photography sculpture and printmaking at
syracuse university while taking an
animation class he completed his first
film tube tales which received a
nomination for a student academy award
in 1976. he enrolled at cal arts and
then began training at disney on the fox
and the hound but left in 1981 to
sequence direct on the cut out animated
feature twice upon a time he then
directed several stop-motion commercials
creating storyboards for return to oz
and nutcracker he was selected to direct
nightmare before christmas which was
followed by the stop-motion feature
james and the giant peach and monkey
bone a mix of live action and stop
motion his stop-motion animation work
can also be seen in the sea creatures of
the life aquatic of steve zazu most
recently select served as director
producer screenwriter and production
designer for the oscar nominated
animated short film
animated feature film coraline henry
here is a
here's a clip from his student film
seepage
[Music]
next chris sanders chris come on out
chris served as the cartoonist for the
arvada high school newspaper before
enrolling calarts animation program
after graduation he went to work for
marvel productions and then disney
studios he worked as a story artist on
the rescuers down under beauty and the
beast aladdin and the lion king before
being met of head of story on
mulan chris wrote bored and directed
lilo and stitch with dean dubois and
earned an oscar nomination for animated
feature film in 2006 chris joined
dreamworks animation where he directed
the oscar-nominated how to train your
dragon and most recently the crudes
chris sanders
[Applause]
and here's a scene from chris's student
film fun with father
[Music]
i'm sorry i have to do this
but you've proven again and again that
you can't function in society
little murderers
like yourselves
cannot go unpunished forever
so i have taken it upon myself to what
you doing dad
mike mitchell graduated from cal arts
and began work as a writer and
storyboard artist on feature animated
films and television series including
ants shrek 2 shrek iii episodes of
spongebob squarepants and monsters vs
aliens his live action feature film
credits include directing deuce bigelow
male gigolo surviving christmas sky high
and inland empire
mitchell has directed the animated
features shrek forever after and alvin
and the chipmunks chipwrecked and is
currently in production on the animated
feature trolls for dreamworks mike
mitchell
here's a scene from mike's student film
of franny's christmas
but franny learned at school that day
that there's no santa
much to hurt us may
it was gloria ostriger that first told
her
gloria was franny's friend who was two
years older
i thought you knew gloria oh striker
sneered it's your parents not the fat
guy in the silly white beard
it was then fran's schoolmates began to
tease her they laughed and pointed which
did not please her
kevin lima studied acting in theater
design at emerson college in boston
before enrolling in the cal arts
animation program after graduating
because he took assignments designing
characters and animating for the
independently produced feature of the
brave little toaster before joining walt
disney feature animation in 1987 for the
following six years he worked in one
capacity another of each of disney's
next five animated features oliver and
company the little mermaid the rescuers
down under beauty and the beast he then
took the director's chair on a goofy
movie which was followed by tarzan and
his first live-action movie 102
dalmatians his most recent film
enchanted combined a mixed of
traditionally animated live-action and
computer-generated characters currently
cabinet is in production on an animated
bollywood musical for dreamworks
animation kevin lima
lima
i'm from ohio where it's lima you know
what can i say
uh
yes glee which is not like lima anyway
let's take a look at kevin's student
film let's misbehave
eric goldberg is a director designer and
animator whose early forays into super 8
filmmaking earned him a full scholarship
to pratt institute in brooklyn new york
he began his career as an assistant
animator on richard williams raggedy ann
and andy a musical adventure after
co-founding pizzazz pictures a
commercial studio he joined disney and
began work as anime supervisor animator
on the wisecracking genie in aladdin he
went on to co-direct pocahontas animate
the feisty fill in hercules and then
directed wrote and animated two
sequences for fantasia 2000
uh carnival of the animals and rhapsody
in blue recently goldberg served as
supervising animator of the trumpet
plane alligator louis in the hand-drawn
feature the princess and the frog eric
goldberg
[Applause]
uh here's a scene from eric's uh student
film for sale
six thousand says it's yours
all right
six thousand for what
why this my friend is whatever you want
plan
one snap of the fingers brings whenever
locale you desire
paris
[Music]
the wild west
ron clements started the disney's
animation talent development program
shortly out of high school in 1974.
mentoring under disney legend frank
thomas he became an animator on the
rescuers pete's dragon and a supervising
animator on the fox and the hound became
a director on the great mouse detective
and partnering with long-time
collaborator john musker co-wrote and
co-directed the little mermaid aladdin
hercules treasure planet and the
princess and the frog
clements received oscar nominations for
treasure planet and the princess and the
frog please welcome ron clements
here's a scene from ron's
early work shades of sherlock holmes
ah
i think i'm beginning to understand
[Music]
this isn't a gravestone at all but a
cleverly designed secret passage
are you coming overboard
why are you that is um
oh i suppose so
pete doctor won a student academy award
for his film next door in 1992 upon
graduation from cal arts he began
working at pixar where he served as
animator and co-wrote the original story
on toy story served as a storyboard
artist on a bug's life and co-crafted
the original story for toy story 2. in
2001 he turned his attention to monsters
inc for which he conceived the original
story and took the director's chair
doctor received an oscar for animated
feature film for up
which he co-directed a co-wrote and
directed he also received oscar
nominations in the best original
screenplay category for toy story wall-e
and up animated feature film for
monsters inc an animated short for
mike's new car please welcome pete
docter
[Applause]
here's a scene from pete's student
academy award winning film next door
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Applause]
so gentlemen on behalf of the academy
and seagraph i want to thank you all for
being with us today uh obviously
animated feature directors is kind of a
small club and uh i'm very proud of the
accomplishments that you've had and i
want to talk to you seeing these student
films about uh where you saw yourself
when this film was when you made your
student films and what looking at it
today
uh
will you remember about that learning
experience and what you've kind of kept
with
what it was that you kept with you other
than perhaps oh my god i've got to get
better
what what was it that you were learning
at that particular time that served you
to make a jump does anybody have
anything they want to jump in well i
learned i didn't want to be a cell
painter
so i learned that pretty quickly but uh
i think i was in that one that was
actually my first hand drawing animation
i had done clay animation prior to that
and
i don't know why i didn't keep up with
that but
but i think i when i got to ucla we had
my plan was to do clay animation but
when we got to ucla
i had to do this test with my drawings
and i said hey look my drawings are
moving so i got very interested in that
and
i just was trying things out that was
sort of the first real experiments i was
doing with animation so yes i thought i
had to get a whole lot better
i think for me going in i thought it was
all about drawing and that's what i was
focusing on and by the time i got out i
realized it's more about acting
and storytelling and so that's what i
was sort of figuring out and it was a
great experience showing
films in front of audiences even though
today it's sort of embarrassing
but at the time it was great just to
hear what people responded to and what
they didn't and start to hone
your storytelling so
i think i learned how to tell a story in
two minutes because that's as long as a
small super eight reel of film was oh
yes
but that kind of uh that kind of economy
is actually held very well for me over
the years to be able to get things to
read in very short amounts of time
anybody else
yeah i am
at that point in my life i was probably
only planning no more than two months
into the future i didn't have any huge
dreams but i was
really just hoping to make short films
i'd seen a lot of films from the
canadian film board which are very
inspiring to me
so primarily i was experimenting i was
fine i was trying out all the sorts of
animation that existed at the time
drawing cut out some stop motion pushing
play around so it was um
you know a time of exploration which i
still try to bring into any any project
that i'm
up to i just
like to bring stuff to life and see if
you can get an emotional response from
an audience
what i was constant
is this thing on what i was
concentrating most most on i remember in
my student days particularly
my film child proof
was uh trying to understand better and
and uh illustrate uh basic principles of
animation i was trying to to have a
better understanding of how to make
character walk with a convincing sense
of weight i was trying to to i was
experimenting with squash and stretch
and and distortions and and i was
learning a lot about overlap by choosing
a character with a trunk so it was
really uh for me it was it was an
exercise in in
not only storytelling but but really
trying to deepen my understanding of
animation principles
i'd say for me i wanted to make a movie
and uh when i was kid and animation
seemed like a way that you could do it
all by yourself and
i didn't have a lot of friends so so it
was it was um
so i could make a film where i could do
the voices i could paint the backgrounds
i could paint the cells and i made the
cells i did all that and and i sort of
did everything and i feel like i got it
out of my system which is a good thing
because um because beyond that when you
really animation is a super
collaborative sort of
sort of uh work where you work with many
many talented people who do all kinds of
things a lot better than you can and and
um so i think it was good to get that
out of my system and and then later
learn how to collaborate
but you were doing the film we saw in
high school already and and uh so this
was a really early
career choice for you
yeah i i sort of
i don't know it was that early i wanted
to get into animation i think when i saw
pinocchio when i was nine years old
and i don't think that's that unusual
something sort of inspires people so i i
was interested in animation and and
didn't know much about how to get into
it at all i think at that time um
just sort of looked at books and and
picked up what you could and and
fortunately for me
disney was actually
starting a talent development program um
in the in the late 70s i think
or actually the early 70s right actually
was right after jungle book
um shortly after after i think they were
thinking of phasing out animation for a
while after walt died and jungle book
was a huge success so they they started
looking for young people who didn't know
anything which was that was kind of part
of the thing they wanted because they
felt like if you would work somewhere
else they'd have to unteach a lot of
things so so they wanted people who were
sort of fresh and and
and which was great because the doors
were closed at disney for years and
years and and it was just sort of
fortuitous timing that they started
opening the doors again in in the early
70s but i bet a lot of it started with a
similar sort of lonely nerdum
that would be my guess
speak for yourself wow that was true
anybody relate to that here
anyway mike you wanted to say oh for me
it was just
it was a lesson in finishing something
because i found it very easy to talk
about all the films i was gonna make and
everything i was gonna do and and and
that short film represents that i it's a
lot harder to actually do the film and
finish it complete it uh that and when i
uh
when i worked on that film when i was
animating that summer on it
i taught myself how to hacky sack and so
by the end of that summer i was really
proud of finishing a film and i had some
hacky sac skills i thought that was like
a little bonus that i had
for me it was quite the same thing as
mike's it was really about survival you
know i was like
21 i think at the time you didn't have
to do a film to graduate by the way
right you didn't you did
nothing
it was about how how do i get through
two and a half minutes of film you know
and be sane
at the end of it so that was really
important it was like
how do i get there can i get there
can i be happy once i've gotten there
and it's gonna set up this whole sort of
you know perfectionism that follows me
till
you know today really
you're almost happy are you happy
yeah i'm happy
what's happening
i forget yeah
it was my first i i didn't know that
this was going to serve me well in the
future like with a with a with a with a
giant production but maneuvering around
a shortcoming and in the case of fun
with father that little movie i made i
was i was maneuvering around the fact
that i couldn't and i never could learn
how to animate a character walking so
all the cuts are true all the cuts in
the framing are to avoid showing their
feet and if a character comes in the
little cat jumps in really quickly
because i couldn't make him walk
[Laughter]
i
for my short film i couldn't turn my my
lead character's head so she just faces
you the whole time
she never turns to the side likewise i i
couldn't make my characters walk either
so they're always standing still in the
transition oh very artful transition
yeah artful
actually turned bad david's solution was
even more elegant than that when he was
doing stop-motion films claymation you
know rather than animating a walk they
just got cut off at the waist and he
would slide them around yeah
it worked great
it worked out
walk schmuck
works for the muppets right they
get to do it
i stayed up for about three days solid
uh finishing my my uh my student film
and the last few shots that i completed
um
i realized i i you know i didn't have
enough time to to fully animate this
film so i had to make
uh some sort of shortcut somewhere so a
a scene that i had staged as two full
figures um i ended up staging as just a
couple of hands it's like i just had the
father in close-up have the
hand the bottle of aspirin to the sun
all in close-ups of hands and it looked
very cinematic like i had like i had a
good eye for cutting but it was a total
cheap shortcut so i could get the damn
thing done didn't you have to do the
same thing in beauty and the beast
though yeah oh yeah
it served me well later in life
particularly in in
the big one of the big ending numbers of
beauty and the beast the mob song you've
got like a whole village of people
tromping up the mountain to go kill the
beast and so we cut to hands holding
swords
shadows on the wall you know we cut to
anything to avoid having to animate 20
characters marching across a background
on ones so these these are valuable
lessons
[Laughter]
and one thing i i did have a really
great sort of experience in making that
film we showed it because i
stupidly had it you know painted in the
whole thing but i had a line test of the
film we showed it at the ucla end of the
you know semester screening and it
wasn't finished and it was like getting
laughs and that was a really great
experience i remember coming in kind of
like halfway through and people are just
laughing and i thought well that's good
i'd like to do more things like that
yeah
it was very kind of out of body
experience it's like you were telling a
joke and then but you weren't actually
telling it you told it like you know
months ago when you're
animating it yeah oh there it is
so when when uh you look at these and
you can talk about other people's films
too or you can talk about yours i mean
each one of these films to me has a
really
strong sense of i can see why you guys
are up here there's this even though
their student works i can see a sense of
style they're all very different and but
they all uh have a very
strong feeling of somebody who knows you
know is is on the way to knowing what
they're doing so what do you see or what
did people see in your work at that time
or what do you see uh in the films of
the other panelists here that you think
indicates uh something that that as an
instructor or as somebody uh coming up
you would say oh that's that's
interesting
anybody
i remember at keller it's one of the
first things they did was to go look at
all the other films that have been done
before and i remember hitting on chris
sanders a couple of your films and
thinking man this
guy is really good but more than that
he's very unique and specific and it
wasn't just trying to be somebody else
and trying to draw like chuck jones or
you know a lot of people were doing that
he just had a real specific sense of
uniqueness that that made me gravitate
towards them not just in the drawing but
in the the storytellings and the types
of films that you were doing so
i thought that was something i still
look for today like when you go to the
movies you don't want to see some
corporate thing you want to see
something that has a strong unique
sensibility from a person that made it
you know
so
well i see in each one that it's like
wow what's going to happen next so
that's always a very important thing of
like you're compelled by the filmmaking
and the storytelling the acting and the
composition that this is intriguing and
so we just saw clips and it's like i
need to see all these films because i
want to know how does it end or how does
it begin even because it's just so
that that's a mark of like this is this
person is a storyteller i need to know
what's going to happen in the next shot
i think in many cases you can see our
nascent sense of humors coming out in
these things too i mean i think they all
have well most of them you know they're
trying to be funny have a sense of
where
some of us got to uh in later years um
and you know to echo david yeah it's
great to actually see somebody laughing
you know at something that you've
produced you know and uh
you know
it was
you know it means what you're doing is
working like an old vaudevillian okay
that joke worked this time you know time
to laugh but uh it was i think you can
see everybody's kind of unique take on
things
anybody else
okay
i'll move on uh
you mentioned pinocchio i'd before we go
move forward a little bit in your
careers i want to just go back to the
germ a little bit one more time talk
about the films and or the moment when
you kind if there was one or moments
maybe where you kind of said okay this
is what i want to do or how did you
discover
the trail that got you to where you are
oh boy i started uh uh really early i
mean obviously i was i was uh one of
those kids who who
who and i'm sure
you know we're all come from the same
cloth who grew up watching uh the warner
brothers cartoons on saturday mornings
and uh you know watching wonderful world
of disney on sundays those were like my
my you know first
my first exposure to to full animation
and i had always loved cartooning and i
my original ambition was to be to be a
comic strip artist but uh by the time i
hit the fifth grade i started
experimenting with making short films
you know with cutouts and pieces of clay
and my interest started to veer more and
more towards filmmaking and away from
comic strip art
they sort of traveled on parallel paths
for a while but ultimately by the time i
got to high school
i was determined to learn animation and
uh you know through the preston blair
book both preston blair books and and
the art of walt disney by christopher
finch
and eventually i learned about uh about
cal arts and i just and i was just
completely focused on getting into that
school
and uh you know spent spent uh my senior
year trying to build a portfolio for it
you know the film that i submitted as
part of my portfolio was was absolute
crap but
i mean i'm really glad they didn't pick
that one for
for this particular uh particular forum
but uh
but i was determined to get in there
well i echo just everything you say is a
similar upbringing in that but in
addition my my dad was a huge wall kelly
fan so when we were kids i mean kids i
mean like five years when i was five
years old he would read us while kelly
and he like you know he'd do funny
voices and things like that and i loved
it i loved the drawing i didn't
understand half the writing because i
was five but the drawing was terrific
and my dad's enthusiasm was great the
other thing my parents did which is
rather interesting is when i was about
the same age they took me my brother to
see
a charlie chaplin double bill you know
of
gold rush in modern times and
we both loved it and that that i think
that when i look back on it that
probably made an early impression of
sort of comedy and uh and pantomime and
so
and likewise i was interested in doing
being a comic strip artist but yeah
about the same age i started diverging
and getting more into the idea of doing
filmmaking instead so but those two
things i remember being
important
yeah i um
you know grew up close to the same time
as as these folks some times earlier as
long as later but um
i saw the same things um but i also you
know i saw ray harryhausen films i don't
know if you're familiar with him but he
was a stop motion pioneer
he did amazing monsters in films like
seventh forge of sinbad jason and the
argonauts
films that although pretty crude in
comparison to the big cg effects of
today they hold up pretty nicely so
i found i was attracted i was scared and
attracted to monsters
in animation so i loved the cyclops and
that he created in the
swordsman skeletons
in disney
um
i i particularly loved
101 dalmatians cruella de vil was my
favorite character
knight on bald mountain was my favorite
part along along with sorcerer's
apprentice of fantasia so i was drawn to
fantastic
monster
appreciated humor and great design
but a sort of
multitude of influences and then and
then short films from abroad from
canadian film board there was a
an animator caroline leaf who really she
pushed oil paints around under camera
spent forever but she did powerful adult
stories
like the street
um was a was a
a real influence so i was i was i had an
appetite for many different types of
animation
um but i'd say there was this through
line something dark more adult
um with a
with a sprinkling of humor
that's cool i think that i grew up in
colorado
and all the animated films that i i
loved i knew they were coming from
california which seemed very very far
away so i don't think i ever really
thought i would ever
end up there doing that kind of thing um
but i remember there was a there was a
there was a i loved to draw and and and
i drew little comics and things like
that but i was watching the wonderful
world of disney i'm pretty sure and they
showed the three caballeros um and there
was one sequence from that from that
movie and that was the sequence the
moment that i really decided i want to
try to do this and that's a little bit
that ward kimball did and it's the song
it's the song of the three cavaliers
song and it was the most
it was so fun it was just it and it took
advantage of animation like all the
strengths of animation things come and
go and it's just it's quick and it's
ingenious and i was absolutely thrilled
by this by this thing that i saw and i
remember i still remember how i felt
when that finished my heart was beating
fast and um and in the days before the
internet i thought to i want to try to
be an animator so i decided to be
be behave
as an animator might and so i i
tried to find information on what
animators do and so amongst the things i
did was i had my grandfather helped me
build a light table and i had really and
truly no idea what it was for
but the drawings i was go i normally did
on the kitchen table that were flat now
we're being done on an angled piece of
glass that was lit from the back
so i didn't know what invitations or
anything
and honestly it was when i got to cal
arts i couldn't tell anybody that was
around me that i didn't know what these
things were for and like we we got a
really quick lesson in between and i was
like i
that's what that thing is for
it puts the drawings in between it's
genius of course
that was the moment
are we going on the line is it my turn
yeah i i'm i was i'm from oklahoma so i
went out to cal arts for live action and
my filmmaking sensibility was very silly
and goofy and at the time at cal arts
the live action people they were very
serious and david lynchian and like
films about suicide and vampires and
grandpa's dying and stuff like that i
wasn't quite fitting in and i went to
the animation department and i saw a
group of people that were drawing
pictures for each other trading artwork
like it was like a community and i was
like i got to get over to this
part of the school and so fortunately it
was bob windquist was the dude in charge
there and so i did a quick portfolio uh
that night and like presented it
he barely looked at it wonderful come on
over
fortunately but it was like what pete
was talking about when you're looking at
his drawings it was such a community
there it was like everyone was like in
the same like desks were next to each
other and there's like it was like
smells a lot yeah it wasn't it wasn't uh
it was like a sweatshop but at the time
it got you ready for real life that's
right
let me prepare to be crammed into a room
with a bunch of people but it was cool
because you would be around a whole
bunch of different styles uh and and but
everyone was very sharing and even if
they weren't like at night like a
stalker i'd go up and i'd look through
your desk pete i'd like look through tom
mcgrath stuff what's he working on
and it was just like a really really
cool uh like a community it was like a
really cool environment and that's what
got me super jazzed about animation
my mother tells a story that she took me
to go see jungle book when i was seven
the original release and i said after
the the king louie sequence that i want
to be like you
that i was going to draw that when i
grew up
and she said she thought nothing of it
she said yeah great that's that's
wonderful we grew up in rhode island
we're a pretty poor family so we didn't
really think that we could break out and
and do anything that was special
so um it's funny because i look at it
from where i am now and i haven't been
able to escape
making films about singing monkeys
that's a positive thing but from there i
just you know i i went to emerson
college to begin with i got sidetracked
for a moment thinking i would go into
the theater i was a puppeteer growing up
and i i was part of an uh a uh a
professional company as an apprentice
and i thought this is really what i want
to do i want to tell stories with
puppets and what i realized from where i
am now is that really what i really
wanted to do was tell stories in which i
could control the things that were on
screen
i looked back and i realized that that
there's a little bit of that god complex
that's why live action is so tough for
me i don't know how you find it but oh
it's easy yeah
getting an actor to do what you'd like
them to do um but without opposing them
moving them around you can't do that
you're not supposed to um
oh they're crazy about that but halfway
through that year i just felt like and
maybe this is it too i was at school
with actors and i couldn't control them
so i thought i what am i doing i want to
be in animation i oh bose wanted to do
this and i went on this little side
track here which ended up being a great
sidetrack because it helped me later on
moving into the telling live action
stories um but i went out to cal arts
not not knowing a soul not having
visited got off the plane and saw my
first palm tree
overwhelmed by the whole experience and
and from there
you know it's so has grown i have this
like aching ambition to always do things
that that i haven't done which keeps
pushing me and i think it was what
pushed me to go and get on that plane
and you know come to california to
actually raise my hand and say i want to
be an animation director and have them
all like look at me like i was
crazy um and then from there say i want
to do i want to do live action and i'm
raising my hair now saying i want to go
do a broadway show so um
you know it really comes from that place
of just hunger you know i've just always
hungered for the for the next thing
well i'm probably older than most of you
okay thank you thank you and
i
remember when um
when i was a kid
you know tv was still kind of in its
infancy
uh
and there was very you guys are lucky
because in the digital age you can go on
to youtube type in practically any
animated film in the history of creation
and see it
and
in those days you had to find stuff and
the information was very very little
what we had then was
the disney program um
the uh the art of animation book by bob
thomas
and the woody woodpecker show and
i got hooked on that really early
because every week walter lance would do
a sequence on how animated films were
made we put these on the light box here
and this is how we draw woody
and it
i ate it up with a spoon and
you know you're talking about not
knowing what a light box is for um early
on i started doing the two-page
flip animation and
eventually graduated to flip books but i
figured out i don't know how but i
figured out that if i draw it against
our plate glass window that works like a
light box
so i did a lot of animation early that
way but i always
loved the feeling of animation the fact
that it was larger than life so
exuberant so fun and i i i always wanted
to do it
well yeah i was going to say the same
thing you said but i'll say it anyway
because we are probably about the same
age and and i watch the woody woodpecker
show religiously as well and and my
favorite part was that part when they
when walter lance would take you behind
the scenes and it was so fascinating it
was like revealing how a magic trick was
done and and
animation always seemed magical to me it
was like just
um really fantastic and and it was um
and the walt disney program on sunday
nights they used to have would also once
in a while they would have an episode
where they would take you behind the
scenes yeah the tricks of the trades and
you'd see animators at work you'd see
them do their drawings
and and as eric said it was so hard to
find out much about animation i would go
to the library and scour for books there
were there's basically three sources and
they're they're still very good sources
but you have to find them there's the
preston blair book the walter t foster
book actually has everything is in that
book
if you know what it is but usually
you're a kid you get that book and you
you don't know what any of it is so it
doesn't communicate but but all the
information is actually there and then
there was another book um um the art of
animation the bob thomas book that went
into the making of sleeping beauty and i
must have checked that out the library
about um
20 or 30 times i should have stolen who
had it yes
i should have stolen that book i mean
i don't know that anyone else ever
checked it out i
kept checking it out over and over but i
always returned it
but um that was a great book but um but
that's cloud yeah just as far as i know
it's me um and yeah you say now there's
so much more information available
for me it was the wonderful world of
disney and you'd every week you'd be
like please be animation please oh it's
charlie that won some cougar
sammy the seal who thought he was a
raccoon
but i was also lucky enough i went to
this school i grew up in bloomington
minnesota and they had a program where
you could hook up with a local company
and i found this
animation firm called bajes jones and i
don't know why but they said sure come
on in use any of the equipment talk to
any of the guys and so i just spent my
entire high school as much time as i
could there figuring this stuff out and
looking at the videotapes that they had
they had you know oscar gorillas reel
and a lot of your stuff and dick
williams and all these commercials
because that's mainly what they did but
it was a great place to learn
and
the other cool thing about being at a
place like that is it's small enough
that it's like a lot of people i talk to
want to get into disney or to pixar or
whatever
and
if you can get into a small place you
have a lot more chance to experiment and
try things and be a part of uh the
really contribute you know it's it's um
it's a great place to start
so i'm going to transition a little bit
now you guys all
started when animation in most people's
head kind of meant 2d and it kind of
meant maybe cell animation or maybe stop
back stop motion but even that was a
difficult thing to do for a long time so
you've also kind of witnessed this
transition and this uh constant change
as to what animation means and
how the business is regarded i mean it
was almost on its way out when some of
you were coming into it and yet now it's
like one of the hottest things going and
yet it's also in a huge revolution so
could you talk about
the the changes that you've seen in the
industry and how you see
uh the methods of survival that you
recommend for people coming into it and
and dealing with the change of what is
still going to be a very much uh
evolutionary process
yeah who wants to go first
mike
what
i'm gonna sound like
come on
uh well i'll say it's uh it's fantastic
who knew that animation would be as big
as it is now and and even for
live-action films there's more animation
in those films and live-action these
days it's insane and um
uh
it's great and the the computer
animation cgi that's like just a new
tool to expand on everything that's been
done in the past and even that's
evolving uh it seems like every month
like there's there's uh new newer and
new stuff
um the only negative thing that i'll say
is uh about it is storyboards are now
done on the cintiq is that how it is for
everyone you don't like that
so i i don't like it and i and i have my
reasons before everyone booze me all
right
because uh it used to be in the good old
days they'd pin it up right and you'd
see it all there and then the person
who's pitching the boards is kind of
doing a performance in front of a group
of people and pitching with it it's
what's known as a stick a pitch and
stick and they point to their boards and
they pitch it and you do the voices and
get to the end and it was just easy to
look at all of it there and like get a
feel for the storytelling and now the
artist the room is dark the artist is in
the back of the room and kind of click
click clicking through their storyboards
right and inevitably it's like oh hold
on oh well that's not supposed to be
there hang on
and it's just like
and i find myself like an old curmudgeon
going i miss the good old days yeah yeah
the voice you do the voice better
wait we actually actually did that
accidentally there was only a few uh
like a year or so ago we were working we
had the that very problem we were going
through someone's sequence and we were
talking about how we saw the whole
sequence on a screen and they clicked
through it and i mean on the on the good
side of it i think the the uh the story
person is they feel like they're a
little more in control of
of the rate at which people are looking
at it and so there's a lot of these
upsides you know it's quick and they can
push a button you get your lens flare
yeah yeah yeah
you don't have to draw the background
over and over which is what i was one of
my slowest things but um but after they
had pitched this sequence um we started
talking about a change we wanted to make
inside the sequence and we we all got a
little bit confused like no no that
happened after he jumped off the cliff
no no dude that was before he jumped off
it and we started getting
let's pin it up let's pin it up so we
can see it and so we had somebody pin
them all up on those old-fashioned
boards we got all the boards out and we
came in the room we were like
this is amazing yeah i can see the whole
thing at once
this is incredible and look i can change
things just like this i can move around
so we got to get back to like doing that
yeah
sure picks it on the thing but then have
it in the other room so you can go in
there and start folding things over and
stuff still evolving still yeah what
they think of next
i i'm with you guys i i really loved i
spent many years in in a story at disney
and i really loved just the
interactivity of it i i loved how
physical the job was you know you we'd
be standing up on chairs and and and
folding drawings back or tearing them
off or you know frantically scribbling
new ideas and pinning them over the
works your core too exactly yeah you got
a good workout up and we would be
hauling the boards to the hall and and
lifting them up and getting them ready
for for you know for pitch mornings at
you know the 6 a.m meetings with uh with
jeffrey back at disney
but there was something really exciting
about it i just it's something that i
miss a lot well plus they'd be hung up
in the hall and yeah and and i would i
would stop and read these boards
everybody would yeah you'd stop and look
at somebody else's storyboards you'd
just be there with your coffee and just
enjoying that and
that really like i missed that i missed
that sort of inspiration being in the
halls
trouble with because this is my first cg
film is that everything is hidden all
the art is hidden in files and you have
to dig through the computer to find
everything and i really miss the the
just being able to be inspired
by something you happen upon as opposed
to something that you search for in fact
i'm a little bit worried now because
like i i think we've all had this
experience i'm guessing but i've gone
into a room to ask about a certain thing
it could be a shot or something and the
person i'm talking to goes oh hold on a
second and they go
like this they write this thing about
this long and they click and the scene
comes up and i'm like
does anybody else know where that is
because if he gets hit yeah what happens
in the head with a hammer
that's where that is are we gonna ever
find it
i i have the same reaction although
although they're talking now about
now doing storyboards i have to see this
this can happen it's like tom cruise in
minority report where you can actually
where you will be able soon now to be
able to sketches around you can blip
them you can change them you could draw
on one with when that happens maybe that
will be the best it might be next week
who knows maybe there's someone here
that knows how to do that i just know
that we we were doing the simpsons
really with the last holdout of not
having it on sales where like 2002 was
the first time we decided we said okay
we have to go digital because everybody
else had gone digital and basically you
know we're getting painted in korea they
said you know you're the only characters
doing it now and we don't want to do it
anymore
we can't hire anybody well i don't want
to sell points
to that we're done done with that and
they started sending things
with deliberate mistakes i'm convinced
there were delivered mistakes you know
things like okay we're gonna truck from
uh 12 field to a uh six field it's gone
out of focus you know better than that
oh yeah the cameraman uh he's gone on to
digital yeah that's it it's a rookie
cameraman i think they're buying it uh
and you know so we were kind of you know
eventually had to go there but it
occurred to me it was like wow we've
been doing this this almost feels like a
19th century technology that we're doing
you know sort of cloister i don't think
we're there yet i was just thinking of
paramount i'm working on the spongebob
feature and i don't know if you guys get
that but we're looking at the big screen
right and looking at color
and i'm like wow the color looks off
they go no no don't look at that screen
look over at this one yeah i'm like oh
it's a little tinier screen i'm like oh
so i look at this for color
and that
so it seems like something that's still
maybe still evolving right yeah i'm
going to get on a soapbox for a moment
here
indulge me
um
i i actually think it's kind of cool
that no matter where each of us have
wound up whether it's hand drawn or stop
motion or computer animation
all of us had 2d in our history
all of us did hand-drawn films
at one point or another because we
needed to know those principles we
absolutely needed to know those
principles i've gone to a lot of schools
you know and seeing that they don't
teach people the hand-drawn principles
and their films are not as strong as
those schools that do teach it
so as far as my advice is never
never
ignore the technology
but don't forget
all it took to get it there
end of soapbox
so anybody else on the technology
question and dealing with change yeah i
think um
it's a incredible time for animation and
also one of the worst times
the film's
the industry has never been more
successful in feature films
cg is the only way they're being made in
this country
the budgets are so high
that i don't think people can afford to
take any risks
so
to make a great film within these
parameters of being very commercial
um you know having to make a blockbuster
every time it puts a
an unhealthy pressure on the creators
um
you know it's it's um
i just see it i think it's gonna explode
somebody's gonna do something different
that'll break through that will be a lot
less expensive i mean chris melidandry
did it with with his first despicable me
he was able to
have the animation done in france at a
much lower price like oh my god look
what they can do but he ultimately
bankrupted that studio had to buy it
and his budgets went when went back up i
just think that it's um
become very very risk averse and and um
you know i can't imagine another
fantasia being made now even though the
attention span of your average 12 year
old is about you know three minutes
so i'm i'm i'm hopeful that there'll be
either a breakthrough or one of the big
studios
will have a big flop and force them to
try something different smaller
but right now i just i just see that um
the pressure on the filmmakers is so
intense to be successful at such a high
level
that i think it stifles a lot of the
creativity
so
so how do you relate that to someone who
is where you were when you made your
student film how do you what advice do
you give them as far as okay this is
what's going on now this is how what you
need to survive it or
unless you're a natural fit unless what
you're doing as a student you'd have to
be very good at it
and if you're a natural fit at one of
the studios i mean they all have their
own
culture they're not exactly the same
but they have similarities but if you're
not a natural fit i would look to new
media i think that
um not everything needs to be in a big
movie screen everybody's got a big
screen at home
um
i think in the way david fincher
brought um english we made an english uh
tv series house of cards live action
and netflix produced it the first
original production of netflix
it's a huge success it's very well done
it brought all these viewers to netflix
um
i know amazon's doing an animated series
for kids
there's there's all these other avenues
and they it's new it's a new frontier so
it's not like a clear easy path
but i would say that consider
looking at
all the other options that are emerging
right now i think it's super hopeful and
you know
you can get anything on youtube if it's
there's a lot of reasons things get
successful on youtube but sometimes it's
because they're good
and
you know so you do a
student short film and it gets out there
and gets a lot of hits
that gives you a much better chance to
continue being who you are
doing what you naturally are good at
um then okay yeah that's pretty clever
but come to our studio and you have to
learn to do an art style yeah i would
say for anyone uh making their own short
film too is to do what you want to do
like this is the chance for you to do
don't make it so you can get into pixar
or dreamworks or tailor it towards what
your mom wants or anything do what like
it's your chance to really express
yourself which it looks like that's what
all these films all of our films are
kind of doing at the time expressing
like really the style and what we are
interested in and i would encourage
anyone doing their their own short film
uh
it's it's you're paying for it yourself
so you should do whatever you want to do
the other thing i say too is the good
thing about
on the upside of technology is i took it
took a long time for me to finish my
film because i you know i had it painted
on cells and i even i even inked it
because i couldn't afford to do
zeography of the lines
i don't think so
they're playing along
so uh
the point is you can make i could make
that film in a much shorter time it took
me over the course of like four or five
years to finish it just because of the
amount of labor involved and now that
labor part is squashed down and that's a
good part because you have more time to
express your creativity and your
storytelling
unless a lot of mechanical things you
can do and that part of the technology
is only get more better faster and more
portable and that's sort of the good
news and i think to what you're saying
is that you could do an
even like maybe like a feature that
could be done for less of a price
because this technology will get uh more
affordable and collapse and there'll be
other programs that you can utilize and
and and
spend more time being creative than sort
of the mechanical difficulties in the
the
pitfalls i think it's interesting always
to kind of look 10 years ahead
because people always tend to think that
the way things are is the way they're
going to continue to be and and it seems
like that isn't the way it ever is i
mean and without making any big
predictions i feel safely predicting
that 10 years from now things will be
somewhat different than they are now
and and
no you could sort of be a part of that
or or not but um but things kind of move
through all the different cycles it's
always interesting and things come out
of left field things you don't expect
and and suddenly everything changes and
and it's like whoa what happened and
and then there's there's new trends and
new things so um
so i think the future
is is really interesting a whole lot of
new possibilities
the other thing maybe to say i don't
know if you guys would agree with this
but in the long run tenacity trumps
talent
that if you are really talented but you
give up and go away
it's nobody's gonna see it but in the
long run if you are doggedly determined
to do what you're gonna do you're gonna
get better because you want to and this
is a film this is a business that takes
five years to make a movie so you gotta
be in it for the long haul you got to be
crazy to do this you do
we're all a little mad
so what are some of the changes that
that
you encountered as you were going along
and and that how did you solve those
those issues what are some of your
problem-solving techniques when you get
stuck i guess is what i'm asking you
mean creatively yeah technologically
both
i think uh one of the tricks that we use
all the time is just list making that
you know as a kid i always felt like
there was one great idea that would be
the answer and now you realize there's
like thousands of ideas most of which
are lousy but some of them might turn
into something good so you just keep
pushing yourself beyond
just the one idea at the beginning so
that's one
the animation draws you in it draws you
in
in close
and and
one of the things i'm trying to do
lately is that when you first come onto
a project
the list making thing for for me is to
write down what do you want this to be
like and before you get into any of the
details of the story like oh i want it
to be i want it to be fun in the
beginning but emotional at the end and i
want people to feel this way and i want
to feel this you write down all these
things
and we put those away
and sometimes when you're so
stuck
you
back away and open that little file up
and it can be something you just
remember a conversation and you'll be at
dinner and you're like remember when we
started this didn't we want this to be
this this and this and you're like
yeah and it's so it's so you need to
back up
back up and look at it as a big picture
again and
and there are so many people along the
way that will help you do that you know
but so many times i'm dwelling on
something this close you know
and
i realize when you back up like oh i'm
bumping against a tree i should just be
moving around that was just sort of
silly but i think that keeping your eye
on the on the on keeping your eye on the
big picture i think and and finding a
way to to not forget what you wanted in
the very beginning but definitely
sometimes you have to back up and
yeah i agree you get you get buried in
the work
and blinded by detail you know an old
trick for
looking at a painting or drawing or
something you've created in 2d is
put up a mirror and look at it in a
mirror and it's like
shocking how you'll see it brand new for
a short amount of time
that's harder to do with
filmmaking but you know
bringing in
outside eyes someone to bring you back
to the big picture
is is essential because animation is so
work intensive um you get eaten alive by
details so yeah great observation i find
that the
beginning of a project is very fun
because it's something new and it's
something exciting and there's all these
new ideas and maybe the last year of the
project
is kind of exciting in a different way
because it actually is becoming a
reality and you see you see it all
actually happening the middle
which can be several years sometimes is
is is can be tough and it's tough to
keep objectivity
and and it really is tough you can lose
your perspective and i do think that
helps to
to sort of
in the early stage when you are really
excited to sort of
uh keep track of what it is what it is
that that is getting you excited and and
trying to keep that freshness in your
own
in your own head as as you make it
through that that
that middle
yeah you know one thing i would say is
that
with today's technology you can do
practically anything but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you should i think
that
you still have to employ smart
filmmaking in your staging
in your characterizations in the
complexity of your scenes you still have
to tell the story well
without saying hey i can have
658 extras you know in the background
walking around here why why do you need
it you know if it doesn't help tell the
story
why do you need it and i think that's
something that's very easy to forget as
the technology gets more and more
advanced
i i find myself as as i
mature as a filmmaker going back to
personal experience a lot of the time
i say i look at a problem and i say well
is there anything in this problem that
i've experienced is there any truth that
i can draw upon to make it real
to make it land in a deeper way don't go
to
you know the touchstone animated films
that i love or something in life that i
can wear as all this or star wars
is there something i was trying to make
it through one day without reference to
star wars pete you just ruined it
i can't get through one day
one day i went to the beach the other
day and i was like oh we're almost to
the end of the day no one's out here
some guy walks by and goes looks like
tatooine man out here
one day
one one day
[Laughter]
yep
i love the movie by the way yes of
course i just won one day without
talking about it i've never seen it
that's a movie
so uh
talk about
was there someone in your
path uh to getting here that was a
mentor and how did they find you or how
did you find them and what was that
process like and what did it do for you
i was lucky enough to have a couple
people like i mentioned in
that studio growing up there's this guy
named bill barter who i sat with and he
taught me basics
along the way i got to meet joe grant
who was
amazing to just pick his brain and talk
to him about what was important to him
in crafting the story of dumbo and
fantasia and all these great films that
he was affiliated with and it really
broadens your mind because you love
these films and
to think of somebody making them kind of
broke my brain a little bit because they
feel like they've always been there to
me you know they're just so great that's
like somebody
from god handed them down and and i
don't know so so thinking about the
process of making them in the same way
that we're doing you know and struggling
with the same things that we struggle
with i mean joe used to say
really not much has changed you know
it's the same problems uh what are you
giving the audience to take home was it
was something that he would phrase it
it's like what
emotionally is this story conveying to
the audience that they will uh that will
resonate with them
so that was a big
for me i was frank thomas that i i
worked with frank um for for a couple
years he was my mentor and i i was an
animator working with him and he asked
me to work with him so that was
that was cool and frank frank is um
probably among animators i think is
probably one of the greatest actors of
of any animators and
and he struggled with his drawing as i
did so we related to each other in that
way and he and it amazed me that he
struggled and it amazed me that he was
um
kind of get got frustrated
sometimes with what he was doing and in
my mind it seems like how can you
possibly get frustrated everything you
you do is is sort of perfect and is a
gem but but he really stressed um acting
and and the importance of what the
character is thinking and what's unique
about the character um and the way the
characters relate with each other and
contrast with each other and how to how
to show that and
and it was um it was just a
really great privilege to just sort of
go in his office every day
during that time and and and
try to be a sponge and and glean what
you can because you realize it's a kind
of a special time but certainly he was a
huge huge influence on me
and um
and just in terms of thinking just
the way the way he approached things and
the way he thought about things was was
illuminating
mine was richard williams
he of roger rabbit fame and uh prior to
roger rabbit he'd been doing television
commercials and things like that
and he was tireless
in
extracting information from
you know
wonderful classic cartoons and and
giving it
you know to the people who are working
for him and uh
i learned so much
from him the other thing i learned from
dick was a very unique sense of graphics
in movement in that
doing tv commercials you're often called
upon to do things in a myriad of
different styles you know one week it's
tom and jerry the next week it's wood
cuts the next week it's fashion drawings
and
dick would
animate anything well and he instilled
that in us
as well it doesn't matter what graphic
style it is it can still have the same
great principles of acting timing
staging
no matter what style you're doing so he
was great that way
for me it was someone who has nothing to
do with animation when i uh when i was
14 i think i said earlier i became an
apprentice at the puppet workshop in
rhode island i became a puppeteer and
i was really taught by this gentleman
named mark kohler who
who instilled in me the joy of
storytelling really that spark at a
really young age and i think what i came
away with most of all was that every day
should be play
you should find a way to make it fun and
i find that's my that's my struggle
now is really how do i how do i reattach
to that 14 year old and have that have
that joy of being in the moment telling
stories
so i have a lot have a lot
i don't know if it's a mentor but like i
said the community at cal arts was
really cool just to be around a whole
bunch of different artists doing their
own style was really inspiring and then
my parents were completely encouraged
i'm sure all of
our parents here did completely
encouraged what we're doing like gave me
art supplies and and uh you know
encouraged me and they weren't artists
uh they i'm from like i said from
oklahoma
and uh never discouraged any anything i
was into or wanted to do with exception
i i did go through a stage where i was
drawing uh devils a lot and see and we
were in church and my mom was like don't
draw you
that's the only time she like said no
to artwork but
super encouraging
yeah i'd have to second that i think
that um that my my immediate family was
was so encouraging of everything i was
doing and um there was a period of time
i had a little underwood typewriter that
like had a ribbon that was like from
like
and there was barely any income i would
bang out these little stories on this
typewriter and um they were short
stories that were all about misfortune
and disaster and and they're really dark
but i would i would type them out and
bring them upstairs and like this is
great chris do another one but i've read
them since and they're really kind of
frightening
little stories
terrifying and stuff um and so my
parents and they were like no matter
what i did they're like this is great do
more you know and uh but also like a lot
of my teachers um i i never really and
this is
this is just i think just the the luck
of the draw for me i never met any of
the art teachers uh in my life i never
met some more teachers that were really
into what i was doing and i couldn't
really find like like cartooning and
stuff like that i couldn't find anybody
that knew much about that um but
surprisingly it was other teachers in
the colorado school system um that
encouraged me like my my laying arts
teacher uh cheryl jones in um in high
school she was like well you don't write
so well but i'm going to let you be the
cartoonist in the school newspaper so i
had that encouragement in that outlet
and one of my high school or my one of
my junior high
band teachers i played saxophone and he
let me do cartoons for their
publications and he did a little art
show for me and stuff like that so a lot
of the teachers in my life actually like
really supported what i was doing and
showed a lot of interest when i couldn't
find it in other places
um
i'll just mention a couple of people
when i was really young i was drawing
all the time and
pretty good for a third grader
the principal at my my grammar school
you know recognized this
and hooked me up with a local
illustrator this pretty famous guy named
stanley meltzoff this is in a time when
they were still doing a lot of paintings
for national geographic there was a
series in life magazine which was a big
deal back then on the civil war stanley
was the guy doing those paintings so
once a week i'd go to his house after
school he had a real studio like a
renaissance artist
if he needed to paint a dead horse there
was a dead horse there hanging from a
chain
there were models he was like the real
deal and i'm this little squirt like
what do i do and he would just sort of
come over and encourage me and
draw my animals and
and draw what i was i was doing so that
was
stanley was a huge influence to see how
one artist you know the classic
tradition of of great painters how they
work
cal arts i i was in both the character
animation program and experimental
animation program and the experimental
the head of that department was this guy
jules angle
jules
exposed me to world animation so i we
saw the classic disney shorts but i saw
things from
poland you know eastern europe
from belgium i i got a sense of what
else is going on and it wasn't all funny
cartoons
there was serious political statements
darkly humorous things many different
techniques um
i ended up
coming to disney and getting a job and
and and then my third um
you know very critical
um
you know to to survive
well there was
basically i was a fish out of water
because everybody else i was working
with there had dreamed their whole lives
of working at disney and could draw the
characters
and under
and understood um the principles and i
was more i was doing like new yorker
cartoons that came to life
things that made sense in a certain
world but not at
disney um
actually i'll mention glenn keane
because
he had gone to cal arts right before me
he took me under his wing
and he got me to draw rough he got me to
to explore and
understand the principles of what the
hell disney animation really is about
so glenn who's draws like michelangelo
is one of the greatest
artists who's ever worked in animation
was the third
mentor for me
you know in many ways my first mentor or
animation was eric goldberg
we met in uh 1974
uh at a kodak uh movie award competition
for the teenage movie award competition
when we both won uh in it and they they
place this together uh they have the
event at the plaza hotel i guess it's
when kodak had a lot of money back then
we were uh
yeah
and we're roommates and
eric's work was like phenomenal it was
for sale was in there and i was like wow
this is
really great great stuff and uh so eric
really we became very good friends and
eric encouraged me and
yeah he was like my first mentor
and i would say
the other one that comes to mind was i
was very fortunate to get to know and
become very friendly with
bill scott who was i'm sure many you
know was the co-creator of the boeing
show and you know
wrote a lot of the material and did
several voices it was actually
interesting for him because that was a
later part of his career was doing these
voices
but he was very encouraging it was and
it was it was helpful it wasn't
specifics but just encouraged he said
something once to me said david a lot of
people draw well but you draw funny
i think that's a good thing so uh
um
so
he was a great guy and it's a it's a
real pity bill sadly died
at the age of 65 before the real
renaissance of animation came about and
i i wish he got the chance to see that
he would have been very happy yeah
i'd have to uh
i think one of the most pivotal mentors
in my early experience was at calarts
was
our color and design teacher bill moore
it was one of those rare
classes and rare
teachers that comes along that literally
changes fundamentally how you look at
the world
the language of color theory and design
and the principles of a design
were utterly new to me i had never heard
any of this stuff before and and it just
you know blew the top of my head off and
affected the way i watched movies it
affected the way i arranged furniture in
my room
suddenly you know
it was like seeing the world through
through a different set of eyes
and uh uh
believe it
the sort of
uh
the sort of twin pillars of my of my uh
experience at cal hearts would be
represented by bill moore and then our
caricature teacher t he
who just had this wonderful sort of
off-center vision and and and wonderful
whims sense of whimsy and humor
and he would sit down with me and
painstakingly go over all my storyboard
panels that i had drawn and just suggest
little tiny tweaks you know changing the
angle on something this much changing
the expression this much just to add
more interest more humor more whimsy
and
i remember t
always emphasized uh uh
you know
teaching us ways to to kind of shake up
uh uh
what we were doing and kind of clear
away the cobwebs and look at what we
were doing in a fresh way he would
encourage us to like draw upside down
with our left hands or if you walked a
certain way to school one day walk a
different way the next day
and and i just loved him for that he was
he was just a really wonderful and
special human being so i would have to
say
bill moore and t he
so i have a couple of questions from the
academy's twitter and facebook followers
i want to
bring to you
matt campana has asked what do you do to
uh currently to keep yourself creatively
flat fresh
and how has that changed over the years
anybody have any
creatively fresh secrets
well i mean you're always looking for
new stuff to be inspired by right and it
comes from anywhere comic books uh i'm
taking banjo lessons uh you know just
you never know where you're gonna get
ideas from so yeah i think i think pete
pete makes a really good point keep
yourself open to to uh uh things other
than animation and other than than than
film
and go out and seek experiences in the
real non-animation non-film world you
know walk your dog go to the beach
i hang out with my kids hang out with
your kids
they're not jaded
no don't hang out with my kids
i hang out with me
no i think that's really that's really
smart like i do other things they do
something else but don't do one thing
all the time because yeah you'll become
sort of i think blurry to it and stuff
like that do do your own drawings right
uh write other stories um uh because you
know not every story has to be a giant
feature film like do a little short
story sometime and just like illustrate
it or something like that or just or or
commit something to video like right
away with a with your little video
camera or something like that
get away from what you're doing once in
a while i think the same way you have to
look away from your screen constantly to
to keep your mind together i think the
same thing with life is you got to look
away from what you see every day yeah
and plant yourself in situations that
maybe aren't the most comfortable
comfortable for you to be in
you know go on a trip somewhere go by
yourself you know figure it out
interact with people you don't know well
i used to think it was all about
draftsmanship and technique and if i
could just draw the right way then i
would be great what you realize is any
art form
the art is a reflection of the person
inside so what you really have to be
focused on is who you are and what
you're doing with your life the way you
think and the way you interact with
other people is really key
that's the thing too interacting with
other people right and getting away from
the screen you know be brave be brave
enough to go out and experience the
world
i just i just
did a little
pitch for my wife's movie sorry about
that
i am in my dna there you go
oddly enough whenever i'm working on a
movie i get to a period where i'm
somewhere deep in the second act and i
forget to go see other movies and so
it'll be like six months i'm like i
haven't seen a movie for a while i'll
finally i'll finally go to the theater
i'm like movies are awesome
and i'm as i'm watching the movie i'm
like i know exactly what to do on mine
now
even though even though the movie i'm
watching has nothing to do with my film
there's something about the audacity and
the and the grace and and the pacing and
the depth of these things that you're
like yeah like that's what i should be
doing on mine you know the same thing
happens if you don't watch tv for a long
time like a car commercial is like oh my
god so the most amazing car commercial
so exciting
i would i would also add to that read
read everything you can get your hands
on read the newspaper read novels read
non-fiction
it all of it's great and all of it just
just refills the the creative battery i
remember hearing a story i i'd have to
re-look it up but it was something
somebody was asking johannes brahms what
he does to inspire his compositions and
he says
i read a lot
you know
i find that
no matter how mundane the assignment is
there is
always a challenge in it
and i think that's how i keep fresh it's
the kind of thing what in this haven't i
done before
how do i solve this particular issue or
set of issues
and
when you're doing something you've never
experienced before that always keeps you
fresh because then you have to go
through the learning and exploration
process to actually find it out
next uh question here is from pamela
kohler it's what are the biggest holes
in the education of most young animators
what can students and beginning
professionals do to fill in those gaps
so what what are people not getting
that they need when they come to you
guys and they're starting out
depends on which students you're talking
about
is there a trend anywhere that you see
where uh that students are coming and
not having or
what's let's try it a different way what
is when when you obviously people think
uh if only pete doctor would call me i
could have a career well you're busy
right so when you do have a student or a
young professional that you're working
with what is it that gets your attention
and that makes you kind of decide to to
mentor them what what is it that
gets you to see
something there that
maybe like your mentors saw something
and you what is it that you're uh
looking for that that gets you or is it
different
for me it's it's i would have to say it
boils down to the ability to convey a
simple idea clearly it's the ability to
communicate yeah i always think it's
that when i look at when i was looking
at portfolios of people it's like oh
these characters have a real point of
view
and they they convey
you know they have emotion they're not
just so i'm a funny character no it's
just like oh i see what that person that
character is thinking or what it wants
and so forth
i think it sends a story i think that
i've seen a lot of different different
portfolios
i just came from uh the comic convention
and people bring up little portfolios on
ipads and things i'm like i always my
main note is is no matter what you're
doing whether it is character design
layout or if it's just you're making a
little film
story a sense of story is is always what
i think
is going to hook me and hook people that
look at it i'd like to echo that i you
know we recently went to some animation
schools in uh
in france and um the biggest note we had
when we came out was these people have a
certain ability
but the most important thing is can you
tell your story
can you actually
tell it in a way that people understand
it and enjoy it and are entertained by
it
and
in many cases they couldn't
i think the technique
is often should be secondary
to your ability to actually convey what
it is you have in your head and that
involves the craft of storytelling as
much as anything else knowing how to use
the camera knowing you know what certain
things in film grammar mean and why you
would use them
that's what i find the most lacking
these days bill moore at cal arts said
you're not cartoonists you're students
of communication and that that stuck
with me
i also think a sense of entertainment is
is is always good and certainly
animation and entertainment kind of
go together but it's um
even compared with live action i think
that that um
there's a there's a fun aspect to
animation in almost every moment when
when when
when an animated feature really really
works well
it's not
there's some films where you sort of go
past the bell parts to get to the
good parts but
if an animated film for it to really
work well it's almost like every
every single moment has some sort of
entertaining aspect to it to help kind
of sustain it it's it's tough to sustain
a story for for an hour and a half
that's um that's probably one of the
hardest things there is to do and on top
of all the skills what i like to see is
someone who has ambition someone who
comes back a second time after you've
talked to them and says what do you
think i made you know i'd made some
changes and i'd really like to share
them with you
that that need to keep growing is
someone that i want to invest in
okay
well i i want to say a couple of things
before we wrap up here one is that the
people in this room are
have a lot of brain power and i'd love
to see you all tackle the concept of
digital preservation and keeping not
only the films that
we've screened snippets of here live
which were shot on other media but the
digital uh formats which are very
quickly changing and are
something that need a lot of attention
there's some careers to be made there
and they're probably in this room the
solutions so i'll
challenge you to that uh richard
williams will be at the academy on
october 4th with an exhibition so hope
if you're in beverly hills you'll stop
by for that
and i want to thank you gentlemen for
making this a very informative and
humorous and fun and engaging
conversation thank you all for being
here thank you
is the best part
we'd like to have a huge thank you
obviously to our illustrious panel here
a special thank you to to our our the
alice davis here who gave permission for
the mark davis lecture series thank you
so much alice for your blessing on this
we've got two big themes here experience
and experiment and we've got a massive
convention center full of all that for
you all right now thank you very much
have a great week